the Joe Rogan experience Eddie Alvarez
is a great guy yeah and I was so up here
anyone I was so happy because we did
some work and I said to him watch
rikki-tikki-tavi which is a story about
a mongoose fight two snakes and it's a
it's a metaphor it's a really cool
matter for anyone to watch it on YouTube
since 1975 cartoon it's a story by
Rudyard Kipling and he's just lots of
metaphors are so not going down certain
areas cuz these steaks were like gonna
kill this mungus long story people wanna
watch is good and I told him about that
and then did some work with him and
stuff like that and it's such a nice guy
he's a great guy you know him going over
to one Fc was a gigantic deal you know
you at former UFC champion in his
problem heads over to one Fc after a win
streak in the UFC but that Timothy nasty
you can guy is no [ __ ] joke yeah if
they don't [ __ ] around that guy's a
straight-up murderer he's a murderer I
was super impressed with him yeah how
many guys like that are out there that
the general public maybe is not aware of
but their elite world cuz alone there's
a lot on that one roster as well yeah
when I look I'm a fake [ __ ] hell
that's what scary see about going over
there yeah because you're going over
there like if you're a guy from the UFC
if you say literally if you're a Conor
McGregor or someone like that and you're
a world champion you're known throughout
the land everybody knows you guess what
they might have somebody over there that
can [ __ ] yeah yeah new person there's
so many of those badass Russians yep
yeah he said that as well but he said oh
he's got he's a third world guys got
nothing to lose he said but I said but
yeah but you've got first world
experience so you've got first world
experience he hasn't and when he when he
walked when he won I was a super pro
samui in Thailand where I go training
and I went it was about 11:00 at night
and all the like wits wit lights come on
you know what people a fighters are not
looking out the doors I was like all
right I was so happy you want cuz he's
such a good guy he's a great guy in that
style that he has like holy [ __ ] like it
has ever been more blood and guts fight
yeah you know and the fact that he was
able to persevere against just engaging
yeah and that [ __ ] crazy war yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah that kid is hilarious to
watch
I mean the best way he saw Pete come on
[ __ ] that kids violent yeah
[Applause]